[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Once you've
built a quality app
and published it on
Google Play, you've
got to start letting
people know about it.
Users have lots of
apps to choose from,
so you need to work to
make yours stand out.
Here are 10 tips you should
follow to get more users
to install your app.
Optimize your Play
Store listing.
Your listing will most
probably be prospective users'
first introduction to your app.
So, make it compelling.
Start with an eye catching
icon and add graphics that
convey the value of your app.
Make your description
apt and succinct.
Use the store listing
experiments feature
to test the graphics and text
that drive the most downloads,
and localize your text,
images and videos.
Your listing needs to pop.
Take your app global.
Users prefer apps in
their own language.
So, localizing your
app can quickly
gain you installs worldwide.
Use the app translation service
in the Developer Console
to request an affordable
professional translation
of your app and store listing.
Reach new audiences.
Extending your app to new form
factors like Android Wear,
TV and Auto opens it up to
new users of those platforms.
Meet the quality
guidelines and then
opt-in to each form
factor on the distribution
page of the Developer Console
so your app can be discovered.
And is your app suited
to families, education
or enterprises?
Then reach those audiences
too by meeting the guidelines
and opting-in when you publish
your app in the Play Store.
Run app install ads.
AdWords is a powerful
and effective way
to promote your app
to interested users
when they spend time
on phones and tablets.
With app install ads on Google
Play, Google search, YouTube,
Gmail, within apps and across
the web on the Google Display
Network, you can also
use conversion optimizer
to automate your
bidding, so that your ads
target users who are most
likely to install your app.
Refine your marketing
with Google Analytics.
Make every marketing
dollar work harder.
You can understand which
channels and campaigns are
driving the most visitors
to your place or listing
and which campaigns are
driving the most installs.
And, with post
conversion tracking,
which campaigns are bringing
in the most users who
take specific actions,
whether that's
making a payment
or something else.
And you can also link
analytics with AdWords
to test which of your ads
and creative work the best.
Get your app in Google search.
By implementing app indexing
through Google search,
deep links to your
Android app will
appear in the Google
search results,
letting users get to your
native mobile experience quickly
and landing exactly on the
right content within your app.
If the user doesn't
have your app installed,
there will be a link
to the Play Store
so they can install your app.
Drive over-the-air
installs from your site.
Let users install
your app directly
to their devices from your
website with one click.
Implement Google
Sign In on your site
to make creating an
account quick and easy.
Then, when users
create an account,
you can offer them
an over the air
install which will push the
app to their device in just one
click.
Outsource for
smarter app invites.
Add app invites
your app to enable
simple, smart, personalized
app invitations.
Once your user invites
someone, they'll
receive an invite to install
your app that's context
optimized on the best channel.
Whether that's a
notification, SMS, or email.
You can also deep link them to
a personalized on-boarding flow
that uses other products like
Google Sign In and Google
Wallet.
By including an offer or
incentive to share the app,
you can continue the cycle
and drive more installs.
Add an app card to
your YouTube videos.
Make your uploaded videos
on your YouTube channel work
harder at driving installs.
Add a merchandising card with
a link to your apps Play Store
listing.
More views could
equal more downloads.
Earn word of mouth.
Recommendations are priceless.
They're one of the most
powerful ways to drive installs.
Create a beta testing
group and engage your app's
most passionate users.
Encourage a rating
or review with
appropriate in-app messaging.
Build your social presence on
YouTube and Google+ and other
networks.
And reach out to key
bloggers and media.
As your user network
builds, you should
take advantage of the community
by releasing your app or app
update across smartphones,
tablets, wear, TV and Auto
at the same time,
so an excitement
builds around your launch.
Users can get in on all
their devices immediately.
And remember, wherever you
have a community or use
marketing, display the
Google Play badge that
links to your store
listing, so users
know how to find your app.
For more information on gaining
users and driving installs,
head over to the distribute
section of the Android
developer website.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your app or game's
performance and how to
build a better app business,
check out the other
videos in this series.
And download the secrets to
apps excess on Google Play.